[audience clapping]
- I'm not sure there's
anyone who's offered
better words of wisdom
about getting through
challenges and doubts,
says my heart and soul;
and we have some people in the audience
who want her advice as well,
So let's get to it.
So where's Connor, and what
do you want to ask Connor?
- Hello.
Hi Glen, hi Kelly, nice to meet you guys.
- You look, James Dean.
Okay.
(Kelly laughs)
- So like you, I recently
moved to Los Angeles.
I moved here in 2019 and
then the pandemic happened.
I'm originally from Maine and
I went to college in Miami and
I've always been super career focused.
I work on the business side
of the entertainment industry.
So I moved out here and was
like, here we go career.
And I realized that once
a pandemic happened,
my career really shouldn't
be my top priority.
So I just turned 24. So I
feel like people are like, no,
your twenties are when you,
you know, you really go for it.
So I guess the question is,
should I continue to stick it
out here where I know there's
more opportunity, or do
I go on the east coast,
which is where my family and friends are,
and I know that I'm probably
the happiest in the long run,
if that makes sense.
- That's hard.
- Sure does.
- Yeah.
- Connor, when you ask that question,
I think about my sister,
which is so strange, she's,
she's helping me host the
podcast and she's one of these,
stick it out type people, never quit.
Quitter. Quitting is for losers.
And I'm more of like a right
now, live for right now.
Quit everything, quit all the time.
And so she would tell you
probably to stay for your career.
And I would tell you probably to go,
and we would both be wrong. Okay.
Because the thing about when
people ask me what they should
do, I don't know what to do,
I don't know what to do,
is that they always do know what to do.
They just don't want to do the
thing that they know to do.
Because the thing that
they know to do is really,
really hard and uncomfortable
and going to rock the boat of
their lives or someone else's life (beep).
- That's real talk.
- Right? So...
- Damn! (blows raspberry)
What?
- So, the bad news Connor,
is that I don't know what
you should do. Right.
But the good news is that
you definitely know what
you should do. Right?
Because we just, it's so interesting.
We're always asking
other people for advice,
but the crazy thing about life
is that no one else has ever
lived your life before.
- That's true.
- [Glennon] Right?
It's an unprecedented,
unrepeatable experiment.
- Yeah.
- Right?
So asking me what you should do,
is like asking people for directions
to places they've never been, right?
There's no map that I can give you,
but you do have an inner
compass, and all of life is just
about honoring that inner
compass instead of other people's
expectations of you. So do
that and keep doing that,
and you'll be fine.
(audience claps)
- I'll thank you down the road.
- And also, I find it funny,
because I used to think like that too.
I'm like, oh, in my twenties,
I should be doing this,
I should be doing this. Look, I'm like 39.
I'm going to be 40, like next April.
And I'm like, I still am
like, what makes me happy?
Where should I go? What should I,
you're always going to
have that conversation.
Like just, you know,
ghost of Christmas future.
It's like, it's never going to,
you're gonna be 60 years
old probably going, man,
I dunno, I could do this now.
Like it's never, I wouldn't
say just cause your age.
I just, I don't know.
I always like to do, like,
what's going to make me happy.
Like in the moment, like
what what's going to be fun.
What seems exciting,
like kind of thing. But.
- And you said that comment by the way.
Yes. You said, 'Which will make
me happier in the long run?'
Go with that one.
- That's true.
- Right? Go with that one.
- The latter. Okay, thank
you so much, Connor,
and welcome to LA and
Godspeed if you leave.
We Can Do Hard Things with
Glennon Doyle is available
wherever you get your podcasts,
and also be sure to pick up
Untamed.
I highly recommend it. It's so amazing.
It's life-changing, in fact,
everyone in my audience is getting a copy.
(audience cheers)